انها حرب المسيرات بلا شك وكل الساحات في
مرماها وفي المرمى اهداف من العيار الثقيل
شبكه ام بي سي نيوز الامريكيه كشفت ان
هجوم الاسبوع الماضي على موسكو بثماني
مسيرات لم يكن عشوائيا اذ يبدو ان
المسيرات استهدفت مساكن لضباط المخابرات
الروسيه في موسكو بحسب مسؤول امريكي كبير
وموظف بالكونجرس الهجوم هو الثاني في غضون
اسابيع يستهدف عمق العاصمه الروسيه والاول
من نوعه على منطقه سكنيه ففي هجوم
الكرملين بدايه مارس الماضي وهجوم الاسبوع
الاخير ثمت رسائل مفخخه تاخذ منحا امنيا
خطيرا يثير تساؤلات حول الاسلحه المستخدمه
لا سيما في ظل الهجمات المتزايده
بالمسيرات خصوصا على مدينه بيلكرود على
الحدود مع اوكرانيا هجمات تشير ربما الى
تطوير كييف برنامجا سريا للطائرات بدون
طيار
قادره على التخفي وفق تقرير لشبكه سي ان
ان الامريكيه
اما اول تجربه اوكرانيه سريه ناجحه كانت
لمسيره مداها الف كيلو متر عرضت نهايه
العام الماضي مدى يعطيك القدره على الوصول
الى عمق تنكر انها استهدفته سواء بمسيره
محليه او غربيه حصلت عليها من حلفاء لا
يريدون لاسلحتهم ان تستخدم في عمليه
تخريبيه داخل روسيا كما يقولون
لمتابعه المزيد من
الاخبار رامز وال
قصص لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا على
اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس
التنبيهات